it's uh rare to achieve such a kind of
dynamic kind of bulletproof opening
repertoire but he has that and magnus
starting in provocative fashion he's
gone for the modern defense
and uh we've seen him employ this before
yesterday with success magnus carlsen
prague has clearly come prepared why
it's h pawn marching forward simon
you must be loving this right now
well the last move is a surprise um
actually i mean i i love
as you know pushing the h pawn and
normally though you prepare this move
first by uh by defending that square and
uh i've actually played this position as
white and black um i normally played it
as white in blitz games as a bit of a
punt
um
but
very interesting idea i mean the
critical we can maybe show the critical
line here i think
because there's only one move that
really you can play i think and that
would be knight takes pawn let's keep an
eye as well and magnus's reaction he
looked so devastated after this move was
played looks so disturbed so let's keep
an eye on the players cameras and let's
jump